i've been thinking bout you lately
maybe you could save me from
this crazy world we
live in and i know it could happen
cause you know that i've been feeling
you aj thank you for talking to us
yeah thanks for having me so what are
you doing for halloween
um well i think my festivities are about
done
we uh partied on the weekend um
just in vegas the other day friday we
dressed up in costumes
um as we played our show yeah so
um maybe once a day take my little
sister she's 13.
trick-or-treating yeah um so
you know this morning we came in you
were wearing batman pajamas yes i was
you have a batman and robin tattoo i do
so
and my wi-fi is uh the batcave
right yeah everything's bad thing so you
love batman yeah this recent batman
movie dark knight rhymes
yeah was it a masterpiece or less i i
thought it was a masterpiece
everyone i was with it must have been
because we were at the midnight
screening
everyone was like dang that was way too
long you know i thought it was
as a whole movie i thought it was the
best one of the
of the trilogy for me as as a whole
but definitely dark knight was the best
like action
you know what i mean like i like that
better in terms of like character
and stuff but as an ending i think
christopher nolan did a really good job
especially me as a robin fan he he was
telling a robin
story without us knowing it was a robin
story
i hope i didn't give it away to anybody
who's hasn't watched this
i mean if you haven't watched it by now
yes that's your fault
yeah your fault no i i think it's it's
brilliant there's so many stories in
this thing that you don't even find out
is happening until the end
you know what i mean so um it's really
the dark knight that like
made me know that i loved batman
not just robin because robin is my
number one guy right
like in the comics and him becoming
nightwing and things like that
um robin is my first favorite character
but these movies did it for me for
batman especially
cool so moving into youtube now um
you know you rose to fame oh writing
right right right stock that rises this
is a nice segue
i know original music yeah original
music yeah
but there are a lot of youtube musicians
that are famous through covering other
people's songs
yeah what do you think about that um
there are a lot of things i think about
cover artists on youtube and stuff i
mean i owe a lot to covers
too you know what i mean but the thing
is like right now
i feel like youtube is getting to be
more like the radio
or you just hear the same song over and
over like for sure if you hear a new
bruno mars song you know that
the the top youtuber musicians are gonna
do them
you know what i mean they all fairly
sound the same i think
youtube is way over saturated covers and
it's
it's discouraging a little bit because
they literally own all the views
right now you know what i mean um so i
just
stick into my thing man i'm just trying
to have my originals transcend
you know the the top
music video of mine is is the when we
say juice box
and i think and
wong fu produced that for me and
directed it
and i think that with a good story
you can tell a lot and i think
when i'm 40 years old you know i'm gonna
look back on those videos
and be like yeah i'm still proud of
those videos opposed to
something that i just maybe did and i
get caught up doing this sometimes too i
just maybe did because
i thought it was going to go viral
because it's number one on itunes you
know what i mean
so i i think in the end of it all i'm
just
doing my thing and even if i don't get
millions and millions
more views or than the other guys who
are just doing covers
at least i know in my soul that i'm
i satisfied what i needed to do and i
think that
means more than just trying to conform
to this new youtube
like movement of just covers you know
you know as an artist you know you want
you want that for your artistry if you
can't write then have somebody write for
you
you know what i mean um so it's just
this i'm just being real
you know what i mean with myself and um
in this community because it started out
where there was a lot
more originals you know the first person
i saw on youtube was david choi
and it was an original song and i was
like this is
amazing it was it was that girl and that
that girl was it it's probably
a big game changer for me you know i was
like dang he can do this and
and get some views you know what i mean
so uh david choi's a big
inspiration for that that's interesting
because you know i looked at your really
old videos
four years ago actually you covered one
of his songs yeah yeah i covered that
song
yeah i was in my room upstairs i had
like emo hair
yeah i thought the same yeah so
so do you think these youtube musicians
that exclusively do cover songs do you
think that they can really be considered
artists
true artists um i think there's a
difference between like james taylor
and um because that's who i really
long to be like a storyteller you know
and then there's just
pop artists like i don't know it's hard
to say
i don't want to be a hater you know what
i mean but i mean like the candy pop
like
like katy perry stuff but i know she's
she's super talented and is a songwriter
as well but
or like kesha or something you know what
i mean that's very it's just very like
shallow pop it's like nothing deep um or
anything
but they're even their stuff is it's
original material
um i mean definitely youtube artists
you know but i i want to be something
more than just that you know what i mean
something more than a youtube artist uh
i want to be a singer songwriter first
and foremost you know before
someone calls me a youtuber but that's
okay to have that label as well
youtuber um no all my friends we're all
striving to be artists you know i'm not
fully there yet either you know i just
i know that i i
found i have found my sound and i feel
comfortable in my own artistry
and these other people who are maybe
still stuck doing covers they're going
to eventually
and i hope they get there as well you
know where you're
familiar with your own sound and
comfortable enough to be like this is
this is me i present this to you guys
and whether you like it or not because i
think
maybe some of these artists are a bit
scared you know what i mean
what they're going to think of their
original stuff because they're getting
so
many positive reviews and like all these
good views on their covers
that maybe they're scared that um their
original material is not going to hit as
much
and you know and truly it won't really
you know what i mean but the original
music will touch who it has to touch
you know what i mean and i think that's
that's the most important thing
um but to answer your question again
they are
they're all different artists and we're
all striving to be a different kind of
artist
so um and we're all doing we're all
doing art which is music
so yeah i believe that we are all
artists yeah
i'll hold the door please come in
and just sit here for a while
this is my way of telling you i need
you in my life it's so cold without your
touch
i've been dreaming way too much
can we just turn this into
reality cause i've been
thinking bout you lately maybe
you could save me from i want to talk
about your play live brief tour
yeah one that you you canceled this tour
recently and you wrote about this on
your website
saying that you know um you set an
example there were these two venues that
apparently had a thousand
uh seats available but only 300 showed
up
why do you think it didn't sell well the
playlist brief tour
was a financial
disaster to be very truthful and
real and transparent you know i tried to
be as as real as possible on that blog
you know um the first thing
that's very that was pretty evident was
that
we literally only had a week
when we had the ticket links up and we
had two weeks when we could
confirm the tour you know i think the
scene is
mildly again saturated because of all
i mean and also because maybe we're
still we still have the same audience
right now we haven't been cross
expanding as well as we should be i
think you know i think there's a big gap
between
the asian american youtube community
audience
and um and the others
you know what i mean like asian
americans to today's
today's just how you guys know we we're
not considered
mainstream you know our look and
everything the ones who do look
mainstream have a different audience you
know
in the youtube community um so i think
we have to
cross promote that a little bit you know
so we can keep gaining traction and
stuff
especially with these live shows because
that's what's going to keep us alive i
think
um well for the people who want to take
that route you know what i mean
um i think there's so many shows going
on
right now that we got to bring something
different to the table you know what i
mean
opposed to just a showcase or just like
you and
your friends who you think are going to
sell sell it out
you know it was really kind of
discouraging it was really discouraging
we worked with this agency who
got us excited you know what i mean we
also ourselves got excited
and we were expecting to to sell at
least 50 of the venue
you know what i mean and then taking
sales were not doing good but we still
had charter buses and we had like really
nice hotels like five-star hotels you
know what i mean and we're all excited
when we get there we're getting per diem
you know what i mean we're like y'all
this tour is legit this
this tour is awesome you know by the
second show after when i
i sat down with my whole team and all
the artists saying yo this is how much
money we're losing right now
the next uh the third city when we go to
boston we get to this hotel
and we get this charter bus we're like
wow we don't even want this anymore
we're like this is whack you know what i
mean like let's stay in a motel
you know let's stay on the floor of our
uh
like our homies you know because we we
knew what was going on and i think
um i think this year
and last year a lot of us are are still
doing
i mean we're writing new music and stuff
but we're still essentially doing the
same thing
at these live shows you know what i mean
whether it's just acoustic you know i i
bring my band to bring new flavor you
know what i mean to bring
a quality show and i think that's that's
a bit different than what we've been
doing the last
four years but i think we all need to
strive to
to do something that they've never seen
before and make it more of an experience
than a show you know i have seen a a
little decline at
you know a couple of at these shows that
we have in our community
that we can't sell sell them like we
have before but i think
you know if we keep um
promoting them well and um
doing all that stuff then it'll work but
just bring something different to the
table
um and i want to go back to you were
talking about you know
cross-promoting and you know being asian
and um
do you think that that's sometimes a
hindrance being you know being an asian
performer that sometimes maybe you're
being like too asian maybe it's not
you know mainstream audiences are turned
away a little definitely but not in a
bad way i think we're doing more good
than you know than we think we are
by showing showing ourselves on youtube
and things like that you know
um i think more asian americans watch
youtube because there's
it's pretty much the only place they can
watch asian americans you know what i
mean yeah
which is it's tough because
you know and i've talked about this in a
lot of
a lot of these interviews when they talk
about the asian american thing is that
well it's funny there's not even i don't
even think there's an asian non glee
anymore
this season but you know when harry sham
was ugly yeah
nobody knew his name they just knew him
as the asian
on glee you know what i mean we're still
all kind of just waiting for the day
when
you know we can just be like man
remember that kid on glee who's like
super good break dancer who eventually
became awesome at singing and
because he had more parts and stuff you
know what i mean and he was given a
chance
to to be in in the spotlight you know
what i mean
um i think we're all waiting for that
but i don't think there's anything wrong
with
um us being loud about it
us being loud that we're asian-american
you know i think it's going to take some
time for
um the asian for there to be an
asian-american
and uh in in every i mean this isn't
we shouldn't be trying to saturate the
scene but i think it's time for
some heroes to be on regular traditional
media you know so other people can look
up at us and be like yo these guys are
mad talented and not just on youtube
i think we're all part of the bigger
picture and like you know i think as
long as we
we keep being proud of it and not trying
to hide our race
you know what i mean that i think we'll
be fine
so take a good look at me
cause i'll show you everything
for you
so for you personally what is what is
success
like for you as a musician what would
you say what would happen that would
make you go ah
i've made it i'm at the pinnacle of my
success yeah
well it used to be when i was 17 16 17
on myspace i was like
i gotta get signed you know it's
obviously
not that anymore you know for a lot of
people
success to me is i i reached success
when i
wrote my first song and i i brought it
to a show and
people were singing along you know what
i mean i think
um from then on it was like only
really go up from here you know and i
think um
when i was in the philippines this year
and i was
i sold out a show in manila every single
song that i was singing even the sloans
that
i play only because i want to tell that
story even the slow
ones with a lot of words in the verses
and things like that they were all
singing along
and that is something that
i can just take to the grave like that
is
a highlight of my life um
just being able to touch people with my
music with my original music and and my
stories
to have them relate to that is a success
in its own
my my dad passed away when i was 10 and
he
uh he was a musician not
making a lot of money
for the family you know
he was telling my mom that he didn't
want us to be musicians because
because of the struggle that he is
having you know
but the fact that youtube and
the internet and partnership and things
like that and
you know revenue sharing and things like
that
we can make music a career
and and the fact that that is possible
and that i can carry on
my dad's legacy just to um
to having a stable career is is success
to me
so and of course having you know a
family
and just being happy i think you know i
truly i even when i was i i first put
together my band and
um things like this we were all getting
said we're like yo we can take this out
we're gonna be huge like we're gonna
you know play for stadiums and stuff but
really that stuff
doesn't matter to me anymore i
i'm just like slowly realizing that um
as long as that i just keep doing me and
i i really don't want i don't want a
record deal
you know i don't want to to get like a
huge advance from a company
and have to pay them back with hard work
and i don't even get to own my songs at
the end of the day you know it's
sad because a record deal is like alone
with like really bad interest
you know and i don't want that i i just
want to continue what i'm doing
um yeah i recently just signed with
maker studios
so that um for a youtube network so you
know
this process of and i'm not controlled
creatively at all in any way
um but i think companies like that are
helping are helping us out
so we don't have to conform to the big
record label
thing you know they've been in control
for way too long we don't need
them anymore right yeah so you signing
to make or see you that's news to me
yeah that's
the first time i'm even saying it why
did you choose maker over the other ones
um maker
as far as i'm concerned was started by
youtubers and
maker music was a huge thing for
a huge uh deal for me to sign with them
as well
um yeah and i know a lot of people on on
maker
you know and and i know knock steady
just you know was picked up by maker and
stuff and
got some of those head guys helping run
maker too so
you know i had a lot of friendly
conversations with him and there wasn't
any
battling like you should sign with our
network because that other network
is whack you know and i've got that a
lot from other networks
you know and i was like why is this even
happening why are they even banging on
these other networks you know what i
mean just present
what you have as a network and if i
choose you or whatever or
if you want me that's cool you know then
i'll choose you but i think maker
had the best and the friendliest vibe at
least for me
you know i even talked to to benny about
it
when i was first signing uh with
when i was first getting emails from
networks and there's
um a lot of really great artists on in
that network
including uh like jeremy passion design
and he was a uh he was a game changer in
the very beginning he was one of the
first
guys especially filipino americans and
probably the first
one of the first asian americans to put
a video online he put on fanatics
of him singing my boo by alicia keys
usher you know and
um he was a pioneer of like the internet
you know
back in the day with myspace and stuff
um so the fact that we're all you know
we're just taking it
we're going flow right now right you
know so that to have jeremy and timothy
delegate on i think i know his side on
maker
um my our other friend melissa palmer
it's just it's good company
so um it doesn't really change what i'm
doing
i'm just gonna keep doing it right yeah
so
you know you put your heart out there on
on this album that's difficult but what
is it like being a public figure
where you know your personal life people
want to know about it and people talk
about it so you went through from what i
understand
a public breakup with jenny suke yeah
and i guess a lot of people talk
about what was that what was that
experience like for you
it's tough because you put your
relationship out there like that
that when it eventually comes to an end
you're gonna have to
i mean you don't really we didn't really
owe it to anybody to say hey we broke up
and we didn't really put it out there
but it was
pretty obvious from like twitter and
facebook and stuff it was a hard time
for me
you know i was like i can't i don't want
to do this again
this public relationship thing you know
and i mean me and jenny are cool now you
know we're
we're on very civil terms like we're i'd
say she's one of my good friends
you know um so it was tough to go
through a breakup with somebody that you
loved and went through all this stuff or
grew together for a year and um
and then people are just keep asking
questions till now
you know what i mean oh my god it's
hilarious on on
google you just type is aj raphael
the top five answers have to do with
like the top five things that come up
automatically
are is they raphael dating jenny sue is
they draft failed dating cathy new and
is azrael dating tori kelly
like people just talk anyways with
anybody who you're gonna do a duet with
but obviously it mostly it was mostly
jenny because
yeah we were putting ourselves out there
a lot you know we were making a lot of
videos
um i mean there was even a point where i
was like i want to delete
all these videos you know what i mean
which i'm sure happens to a lot of
people but you know i
i don't think you should because it is a
good memory you know what i mean like
everything that happened is for a reason
you know
so i um i don't regret anything
i don't regret anything about the public
breakup too i think it was great
for the people who were who are actually
like paying attention to it
that they're like yeah these guys are
human and they go through the same
things
you know what i mean and i think people
can get a little over dramatic on
twitter and stuff like that sometimes
but
i think it's a it's a good wake-up call
to a lot of people and to say like hey
these guys aren't
you know they're not robots you know
they feel something and they're not the
perfect couple
you know obviously yeah we
we had a lot of fights on twitter and
stuff you know but when i look back on
it i just kind of laugh and just be like
yeah that was a good time and
you know it was it was good while it
lasted so
yeah and i understand too that you had
sort of a public tiff
with a singer named dave banda how are
you with him now
we're really good too he just did the
last
show of platelet breath tour with me and
that's when we re this is the first time
in a couple years that we have had an
actual show together where i had asked
him to be a part of it
you know he was part of music speaks
back in 2009
the first one and we had like a public
tip over some stupid stuff and there
were a lot of
like other artists involved as well but
we're all
it's been a couple years and i think we
all can be immature at times
you know and i'll i'll be the first to
admit that i was being
pretty irrational sometimes when
when it came to that like i was like
retweeting nonsense like you know
and like retweeting the haters and i
don't know i
i'm glad it's over and me and gabe our
our brotherhood and our friendship
transcended you know what i mean
transcending any negativity so i'm i'm
happy for that
and um it was really interesting time
it was an interesting time i was i was
hating man
i was saying bad it was you know and
and i mean there were a lot of things on
both ends you know where
we all could have done some differently
but we talked about it
so we're good and um i think that's all
that matters and
some of the the fans still ask about
that as well you know
i get comments occasionally right so now
it's done they're at peace
yeah we're at peace you know there's no
more rivalry
yeah i mean it wasn't really a rivalry
but the fans took it like that
you know what i mean they were so while
that was happening
there were comments on both our videos
every new video that we put out
gabe is better than aj aj is better than
gabe gabe greater sign
aj you know what i mean like all that
stuff but yeah we're good but you
clearly believe that you're better than
gabon
just like yeah right no aj i really
truly believe that gabe is one of the
best vocalists that
you know i've had the pleasure to to be
around
for sure like top 10 for me for sure i i
strive to have a voice like this
definitely can you tell me about music
speaks
why are you so passionate about um
autism awareness
my nephew nathan has autism i have an
older half-sister from my dad
her name is eileen a lot of people don't
know that
she's uh she's much older than i am but
she has a son
and yeah he was diagnosed when he was
very young
we thought not we i guess
my sister thought he was deaf because he
was not responding
you know what i mean not responding to a
lot of things when you call his name
for instance you know um but it turned
out he had autism
and none of us really knew what that was
this i think this yeah this is the first
like
um our our first
relative with autism and like our
immediate circle i have a lot of
uncertainty in l.a and things like that
so it was it's a mystery still a lot of
people are still trying to
solve the puzzle of autism you know it's
referred to
as as a puzzle because just trying to
put together pieces you know
and see what is really causing this and
and why
it's happening and stuff so i just
wanted to figure out
more about it and and bring awareness to
to everybody else out there through my
influence you know
it's crazy seeing how the numbers that i
have and
me being like damn what if i was just
doing this for me
that is the most selfish thing when you
see hundreds
of thousands of like people on like your
social networks and stuff and it's like
to do something for like the greater
good
is i think it's it comes with
it's a responsibility you know what i
mean i mean i do it from the bottom of
my heart because i want to
but i think why why not
do that you know what i mean um
find something that you're passionate
about or um
you know that you relate to and um and
do something for
for a good cause you know with the
influence that you have um
um so yeah i started in 2009
music speaks movement it was just a
movement back in the day
but um as of june we were official
organization
and still filing right now for
non-profit status you know
but we we eventually want to make it
more than just a concert
and we're we're making it
i think what we're trying to do next
year which is my plans are still like
very general but i do want to put on a
little camp or like a
workshop for kids with autism to get in
touch with their music
their musicality because i my nephew
he you know he gets extremely focused on
one thing like a video game or something
he
won't be able to put it down but when
he's singing music it's almost the same
thing
and i brought him up for some of my
shows sometimes to sing
and he is seeing the lyrics and you know
he's
he's a normal kid you know what i mean
to have that opportunity i think to be
able to touch
um that music spot that every kid
i know has would be great so we want to
do that next year and i'm
going to ask all my music speech artists
to come out you know sing some songs and
maybe
go into group different groups and share
your music with them have them play
instruments you know what i mean that
i think it would it would be great for
for us and
to to reach out and not just put on
concerts
which is cool as well you know what i
mean um
but when you're actually going out and
doing something taking action
i think is the best tool of all when
you're hands-on so that's what we want
to do
in the summer i think it's going to be
cool next summer hopefully
hopefully so do you do you know any of
the acts that you plan to
have to have i would love to ask
everyone from
from this lineup and um anyone that
asked to be part of music speaks
is someone who i think embodies
true music and in its art and expressing
yourself through
through through music you know tori
kelly
cameron mitchell matai there's so many
great artists you know part of this
year's lineup um
i would love to ask them tori
me and tori have been you know making
music and i've done a lot of videos for
like a good two almost three years now
so
um it would be great to have because we
know how how we work and
things like that so and i think a lot of
people will be up for the task even the
ones who haven't been part of music
speaks
i'm pretty sure um they're they'll
they'll be wanting to
to reach out as well i think it's
important
do you have any upcoming tour dates that
um well i guess just music speaks which
is november 3.
i am also at the same time i'm
i'm also directing a concert at my
church which is two weeks later which is
the 17th so
it's been tough because i've been going
back and forth and
um like with my parish community sharing
them
sharing with them for the choir concert
and then
with everybody else i'm sharing music
speaks and it's tough because i'm
like my typical sunday is go to church
in the morning
play piano and sing and then
after mass which is it ends at 12 we
have practice at two to four
would acquire for the choir concert and
then from six to nine
is my choir practice for music speaks
with my choir in vcc
so it's been tough but i've been even
getting confused in my mind about the
music that we're doing and these
things um but yeah so that's november
17th
church choir concerts here in murder
valley and my at st patrick's and
can anybody go anybody can go yeah it's
just going to be a good night of music
i haven't been really like pushing it
yet because the because the music speaks
but
i think it would be cool to get some of
our uh some of the community out to see
what i really do i mean
this is why i'm all the way out here in
riverside you know because my family is
here and my churches are here
so it would be cool for them to get a
taste of what i do
just outside of the whole internet thing
right
and so where can people get tickets for
the music speech music speaks is uh
justmusicspeaks.org tickets vip tickets
are still available
general admission fifteen dollars you
know and it it's all for a good cause
they can go to the door to get tickets
as well
and i think it's gonna it's gonna be a
success you know
this year and uh for the church
uh concert you'll see me posting about
that as well you know that's out here in
reno valley
or in riverside but rhonda valley is
just a couple miles away that's where i
grew up
all right aj thank you so much thanks
bro thanks for
i talk so much it's good i think
i appreciate it yeah definitely i just
want to share as much as i can
cool all right thanks for having me
thank you for coming new media rockstars
yo what's up guys it's me aj rafael
shout outs to newmediarockstars.com it's
been an
intense day of shooting with halloween
costumes
candy on the floor which is candy i
can't even eat because i'm allergic to
dairy but
it was fun thank you guys so much be
sure to check out music speaks this
saturday november 3
supporting a good cause raising autism
awareness through the power of music
also i just want to let you guys know
that i
am working on a musical red rose is a
musical and a movie as well so more
details
and i'll be sure to share that with nmr
i'll see you guys soon thank you very
much